Hello, everybody.
Today is a chill day, yippee.
Hello, hello.
It's been a while.
It's been a while since we have a Good Night, Dragons.
It is 10pm for me, so I am definitely at lower energy.
I also got ice cream.
I ordered myself some ice cream.
I am a child.
You guys must be like, why are you a child?
Well, the two flavors I picked was blue cotton candy and bubble gum.
I don't know why.
I just love... I don't know.
I just love the cotton candy flavor.
I always just grab the cotton candy.
If I can, I would always order cotton candy because, I don't know, it's just a flavor that I really enjoy in general.
So yeah, I guess I am just a child.
So I'm like wondering, am I smaller?
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm smaller.
I'm trying to figure out, do I look smaller?
Should I be a little bigger?
I can't tell.
I can't tell anymore.
I feel like I did mess with the sizes.
Let me double check, guys.
Let me double check if this is the same.
No, I am smaller.
Am I?
I can't tell.
Hmm.
I can't tell if I'm smaller or not.
Give me a sec.
Let me double check.
No, this should be the right size.
No, I am.
I can't tell.
I'm a purple.
I'm a tiny bit smaller.
No, that can't be it.
Let me double check real quick.
I just need to look.
Okay, there you go.
I am the same size.
I think I am.
I think I am the same size.
Let me see.
I'm sorry.
I'm like really out of it too, by the way.
I think I'm the same size as I normally am.
As I normally am.
I don't know.
It's like my go-to ice cream flavor.
I always try to get cotton candy flavor.
Because, I don't know.
It's just my favorite ice cream flavor is either cotton candy or green tea.
But it's so hard to find good places that make green tea here in Canada.
Because like, you know, green tea ice cream just doesn't hit, just doesn't taste right in like NA.
Like Asia green tea ice cream, oh my god, it's so good.
But like when I try to eat green tea ice cream in Canada, it just doesn't taste right.
It feels like there's a lack of flavor.
I think that's the right word.
There's just no flavor to it when I try to eat green tea ice cream here.
Even when I'm like going to like Asian places, like Asian ice cream stores or Asian restaurants to try to order green tea ice cream.
It's just, I think it's just like the ingredients here is harder to get versus in Asia.
So like I, now like in NA, I just get cotton candy ice cream because at least like it tastes like something.
If I try to get like green tea ice cream here in Canada, like I barely taste anything.
It's like barely a taste of like a barely any flavor or my taste buds are dying.
I don't know.
It could be one or the other.
It could be both.
My taste buds might just be dying.
I don't know.
The older I get, the less I taste.
And then I need like more sweetness in there to actually like...
I need more sweetness to actually taste anything these days.
Like I don't know anymore.
I honestly, I don't know.
It could be one or the other.
Um...
Let's see.
Oh my god.
Do I... Actually, sorry.
I'm like super anal about this.
I'm like, do I look smaller?
Trying to figure out if I look smaller or not.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I'm smaller or not.
No, no, I was leaning back.
Oh, okay.
No, I figured it out.
It's because I was leaning back.
Okay.
No, I'm a perfectly right size for a cat.
I'm a perfectly okay size cat, guys.
No, it does.
I'm like super like anal about these things.
I'm a perfectionist.
So I hate it when I'm like different.
Like if I'm on the screen and if I'm like, oh...
If something's positioned like weird, like positioning is off just a little bit.
Like everything is off for me.
So I'm like, oh my gosh, why am I a little smaller?
I don't like this.
And then like, I'm very like particular about these things.
It's also similar to like...
If my monitor moves in any way, I hate it.
It like throws me off for like a week or so until I get used to it.
Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki.
What was your choice of drink during massage?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was the orange soju flavor.
I had that for... I had an entire bottle of the citron soju.
Citron?
Citron soju flavor.
Because I think that one tastes the best out of all the soju flavors.
I mean, it's that or lemon.
I think that lemon and peach are the best flavors from soju.
But yeah, I got that for my alcohol, my alky-ha.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Today is a chill day because it's goodnight dragons.
So we're just going to be yapping.
We're going to hang out together.
And just chill a little bit.
I am a little eepy right now because of the blood moon.
It's really bad.
So I am already a little eepy.
I don't know what to talk about.
But I hope you guys have a great day today.
We had a great day hanging out with me today.
And doing whatever you guys have been doing.
For me, I think literally my entire day was wake up.
Exist as a person in bed for like an hour.
And then stream.
No, wait.
No, okay.
No, that's not right.
Because then my stream was at 5.
Alright, exist as a person for two hours.
And then stream.
There we go.
That sounds better.
And then I ordered ice cream after...
After a good hunt where I killed all those kangaroos.
And... Sorry, I'm like ripping.
I have... Okay.
I have this habit of like...
When I... If there's a label on a bottle...
I only do this for bottles.
Like if there's a label on a bottle, I like to rip the label off.
And it's like my way of fidgeting.
Alright, see you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi Doki, hope your evening is good.
I definitely want to post art of you eventually.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you... I hope you do.
I look forward to seeing it.
Just use my art tag.
Doki Gallery.
I had to think a little bit.
I was like... I almost...
Okay, not gonna lie.
I almost said my old art tag.
Because it like rolls off the tongue easily.
I had to think for a sec.
I was like... Doki Gallery.
So that's why I had to pause.
So you hear me ripping paper right now.
Is...
I'm literally just ripping the label off of the soju bottle.
Because I just have a habit...
I have a habit of...
Ripping labels off of things.
Not things, but just bottles in general.
Just any drink related stuff.
I just like ripping it off.
It's just very comforting.
Coyote!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, because I'm a kitty.
I'm Doki.
I'm not Doki Bird.
No, it does not coexist with the feather.
Because this is when...
The feather is when I'm in bird form.
And the ears is when I'm on kitty form.
So this is like the difference between one and the other.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Fuck, okay.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just got back from the hospital.
I'm good, but I just wanna say thanks for being a bundle of joy.
You're an inspiration to me and many others.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Exactly, birds and cats cannot coexist.
But yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you're feeling a lot better.
I hope whatever it was, you're at the hospital for it.
Things are okay over there.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, I wanna say about next week's schedule.
Next week, I wanna play Super Mario Man.
So that's the only thing...
The only thing confirmed for next week is Super Mario Man and Visage chapter...
The second chapter with Min.
It'll be same time, same day for the Visage stream.
So yeah, that's the only two things that I've confirmed for this week.
Just those two.
What are things that I wanna talk about?
I feel so, so, so, so, so chill right now.
I'm like, low energy, don't kidding.
I'm a lazy cat right now.
Meow.
Oh yeah.
Doki Amber Doge did it yesterday.
So like, he likes to...
When he likes to roll around and roll on his back when he's playing with his toy.
And then he got so excited, like, so into his toy that he like, rolled off the bed.
I was like, freaking out.
I was like, like, are you okay?
And then he just like, he just looked at me and then just walked...
Like, I have many stairs.
I have many stairs for him to walk to my bed.
Walk up to my bed, cause I don't wanna encourage him to jump a lot.
But like, he doesn't give a fuck.
He still jumps off the bed.
And he just like, he looks at me and just walks back up in the bed.
Stupid dog.
Oh, oh, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Did you guys see that?
You can use...
There's...
Okay, I'm not talking about like, AI.
I know there's like, AI.
Where you can play Minecraft AI or something.
That was a long time ago.
But someone made actual AI.
You can make AI Minecraft houses in Minecraft now.
Did you guys see that?
That's fucking crazy.
There's like, a new plugin that generates Minecraft houses.
Yeah, in Minecraft.
Yeah.
You can like, it would like, AI generate an actual Minecraft house.
This is fucking crazy.
I wonder if I like, saved the tweet.
I saw a video of it.
I was like, what the fuck?
Like, you don't even make your own house anymore.
You can fucking generate...
You can AI generate a house now.
I...
That's insane.
That's fucking insane.
Like, we're at this point, like, point now.
In life where like, people don't even make their own houses anymore.
Let me see if I can find it guys.
I'm gonna scroll.
I know like, I wrote it down.
So I don't know if I actually like...
I don't know if I actually...
Saved the tweet.
The video of it.
Cause that blew my mind when I saw that.
And I was like, Jesus fucking Christ.
How lazy are we getting right now?
We're AI generating.
We're literally AI generating Minecraft houses.
Just build a fucking dirt house.
Okay, Minecraft AI.
AI house.
Let me see if I can find it.
Trying to...
Alright, let's see.
I don't even know.
Minecraft house.
I don't even know if I can find...
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Here.
They use like...
It's based off of diffusion.
It was crazy.
I was like, what the fuck?
It's so...
It's so like, fucky too.
I don't know what's the right word to say.
It's like...
I know there's like a better...
Like a better tweet of it.
But it's just...
It's so like, weird to see.
Just...
You know.
You put up TNT down and it just makes a fucking house.
Yeah, it looks so trippy.
Yeah.
Like, it explodes and then a house appears.
Yeah, but like, it just removes like the whole point of being creative in Minecraft.
Like...
It just like, removes the entire like, point of playing Minecraft.
Like, you're supposed to...
It's all about being creative and like, making whatever you want.
Um...
Yeah, what's the point of...
Yeah, it's just more...
I think I saw that they made this.
It's more so like, can I make something like this?
It's not more like, uh...
Not like, uh...
Oh...
Uh...
Oh, I don't wanna build anymore.
They're just like, can I do it?
You know?
Yeah.
It is, it's incredibly trippy.
Mac, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
With Doki pray on...
Oh yeah, Doki would eat...
Doki would 100% eat Doki Bird.
100%.
It's a Doki Doki world.
It's called Survival of the Doki.
Um...
Yeah, I like...
I like a lot of random stuff.
Um...
On Twitter.
Also, Rocky Raccoon's meta now.
And I'm sad.
One of my friends...
I asked my friend...
One of my friends.
I was like, how's the new season?
And they're like, it's so fun.
It's really fun right now.
Like, uh...
I was like, okay.
But like, do you think I'll like Marble Rivals?
New season.
And they're like, well, Raccoon's meta.
I was like, okay.
Okay.
It looks like I'm gonna be a raccoon, man.
It looks like...
No, they made it...
They made Raccoon just a little bit more skilled.
Because from what I've heard...
His left click, his heals...
His heals, you have to have the heal land on somebody to do more healing.
So like, it requires some form of aim now.
Instead of just randomly chucking the orbs at people.
So a lot of the shittier one-tricks who can't aim are not climbing a lot.
In our swap...
I saw...
Okay, I saw a game...
I was watching a game.
Yeah, you have to directly hit somebody to actually heal someone.
There are AoE healing, but it's not as good.
It's not as good as directly hitting someone with the heal.
So like, it's really funny.
Because I was watching a game.
And there was this raccoon one-trick.
That...
That was trying to play raccoon.
But obviously, he was a shitty player.
Like, he was a shitty player that can't aim.
So he was like a fucking raccoon crutch.
And then, he obviously was not doing so well.
And then he swapped to Cloak and Dagger for the auto-aim.
He swapped to Cloak and Dagger.
Because he couldn't fucking actually aim.
And then, like...
And this team was like...
Why are you not playing Rocket?
He's so...
Like, you have to have a Rocket to win.
That's the thing.
You need a Rocket to win the game.
Because he's like the must...
Must have healer on your team.
Like...
So...
So like, you have...
At least like, there's more skill now.
Involve your Rocket.
No, they increased the projectile speed of his heals.
Yeah, you need to actually have some...
Like, at least one hand to play Rocket now.
But he's still fucking easy as hell.
It's just, you know...
If it directly hits somebody, it does more healing.
No, I still don't respect Rocket 1 tricks.
I respect support players that can play Rocket.
Because they're usually the better support player.
They're usually just better at Rocket than Rocket 1 tricks.
But yeah, my friend was just like...
Yeah, Rocket's meta.
So I don't know how you're gonna feel about that.
And I was just like, well, I start...
I knew he was gonna be meta this season.
Because of early access.
Like, how strong he was in early access.
So I was just like, I'm not surprised.
But like, I'm still, you know...
I can still be sad.
I can still mourn.
Uh, no name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
On the plus side, every Marvel hero got a buff buff from what I've heard.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, we talked about it during last stream.
Last stream, we talked about it.
How like, all the other...
All the men got like a huge buff on their butts.
They all went to Brazil.
Yippee!
And Wolverine had several buffs.
Dude, the...
He had the front buff as well.
He got the...
He expanded the bulge while he was there.
He regenerated like a lizard and it got bigger.
But we talked about the...
Oh, for those who missed out on the hunting stream.
We were talking about it earlier today.
During the hunt stream.
I even linked it.
But basically...
Basically, so you guys know how...
So there's this buff.
I'll link it again.
There's this one.
And then there's also the Wolverine buff.
That, you know, they never mentioned too.
I love how they didn't even mention this in any patch notes.
It's just...
You know, usually developers would talk about like the cosmetic updates, you know.
You know, they didn't even bother to like say anything about cosmetic-wise.
It just...
It just like, you know, it was like a secret.
Like hotfix or some shit.
Behind the scenes hotfix.
But yeah, that's...
That's basically it.
The secret update.
Anyway.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, currently at work right now.
But I want to say thank you for all the great content you gave us.
All the laughs you bring us.
And Marble Rivals, love you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate that.
I hope you have a great day at work.
And yeah, don't have any bosses yelling at you.
That's the best part.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Trey, thank you for the super chat.
Doki, wish me luck on my battle with cancer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You got this.
Good luck, man.
I hope everything will go well.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What was I gonna say?
Don't worry, we dragoons are here for you.
Okay.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Okay, so I found out that...
You know how every year, Sanrio does the favorite...
Like, you know, the fan poll of which character is your favorite Sanrio character.
And it's now...
You know, they just launched the newest fan poll for Sanrio.
And apparently, there is...
It's the 40th...
Oh, it's the 40th anniversary for the Sanrio character ranking contest.
And apparently, Cinnamoroll has won the character ranking contest 7 years in a row now.
And people are mad.
No, it's 7...
He has had his 7th year win in a row.
And I saw this tweet.
And then I...
People are actually, like, uniting together to take down the dog.
I love this tweet.
I swear to fucking god, if you chocolate dice, let that greedy fucking capitalist dog win.
For the 7th year in a row, I'm going to commit an act of resistance.
And then, it's like an actual war right now.
It's like a fucking war going on in the Sanrio community.
And then, I love, like, the replies.
And, like, you know, it's like...
I will not be silenced.
Greedy or not, we will stand with our leader.
They will not silence me.
Doing my part as a Cinnamoroll truther.
Can't hear you.
My king is winning.
If you guys actually want to take down...
If you guys want to take down Big Dog...
The Big Dog upstate.
You have to all unite together under one character.
Like, that's the only way to win.
So, it's like, thank you for reminding me to vote for my president.
Like, you can't just say that and not, like, band together to vote for, like...
To vote for, like, one character.
Like, that's all you have to do.
And then...
And then, my favorite...
And then, there was a quote or tweet about it.
And I didn't know this was...
Okay, this is a fun fact, apparently.
But, the lore...
So, you know how Cinnamoroll doesn't look like a fucking dog?
So, Cinnamoroll was originally pitched as a bunny rabbit.
And the creator, Cinnamoroll, made, like, was like...
Yeah, Cinnamoroll's a bunny.
And then, Samuel was like...
Oh, we're not looking for a bunny right now.
We actually want a dog character.
A new dog character.
So then, the creator was like...
Okay, he's a dog.
So, yeah, you're a dog now.
And that's why he looks like that.
It's just that simple.
He was originally created as a fucking rabbit.
That's everything for money.
Yeah, because he doesn't look like a dog!
He doesn't look like...
He doesn't look like a dog.
He looks like a rabbit.
But, yeah, he didn't change anything.
He just said...
No, he's a dog now.
JK.
JK, guys.
I said rabbit?
No, no, I meant dog.
And then Samuel was like...
Okay.
They're just like...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's a dog.
Wait, I'll bring it back.
I need more water.
I forgot to refill my water.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry for bringing this up again.
But people are locked out of the Lawn Winter server again due to a recent update.
Could you please take care of it later?
Thank you.
Alright, thanks for reminding me.
I'll go...
I'll go fix that right now, actually.
I can fix the Lawn Winter server.
I'll post this later, but we're gonna be doing...
The tomorrow at 5 PM on Sunday.
Just for the members, we're gonna do the final Battle Royale.
But this is all off-stream, so I'm not streaming it.
Just for you to let you guys know.
Cause I forgot to tweet...
Not tweet.
I forgot to make a post about it.
But just for you guys to know that it will be tomorrow at 5 PM.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, it expires in one day, everyone.
The server expires in one day left.
Okay, next due date.
I wonder if that's like...
Oh wait, no.
Is this 14th?
14th...
In the UK?
Or 14th NA?
Well, we're gonna find out.
We're gonna find out tomorrow if the server is still around.
We'll find out tomorrow.
Uh-oh.
Cause I used the GTX gaming for the server.
So I have no idea if it follows like UK hours or NA hours.
So we're gonna find out tomorrow if the server is still around.
Gamble time.
Yeah, I'm fixing it right now.
Oh, thank you for the...
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I'm a
pee cat right now.
I'm a pee cat.
I didn't do much today either.
I think it's because of the blood moon, honestly.
I honestly...
I think it's just...
I think it's just the blood moon that I'm super eepy.
The loss of blood does that to a person.
I have not had zinc at all.
I should take my vitamins now that I mention it.
Gotta take my vitamins.
Yay, vitamin time.
Did my thing update yet?
Process has completed.
Okay.
Alright, the server's back.
I have...
I have updated the server for long winter.
You guys should have it back now.
There's something I want to talk about I forgot.
What do I want to talk about?
Was it DohKitty related?
Fuck, okay.
My memory's not good right now.
I think it's the lack of sleep.
No, it's just not the lack of sleep.
I've been sleeping a lot.
I think it's just I've been super tired.
Swarm, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay, been a while since Good Night Dragons.
Anyway, DohKitty, when's the good movie watching on?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hmm, I don't know.
I don't know when.
I haven't...
Usually, when I decide...
I try to like...
Um, paste things...
From each other, like make sure it's not like back to back to back when I do member stuff.
In terms of like the...
The theming of what the member stream's gonna be.
So, when was the last time we had a movie watching on?
Let me double check.
Let me look at when the last time we had a movie watch along.
And then maybe...
It was two months ago.
Maybe next members.
Yeah, next members we can...
Um, I...
Since we did like four like back to back to back to back member stream though.
There's not gonna be a member stream for this week.
Or slash next week.
If you...
There won't be a member stream for next week.
Just cause like we had like non-stop member streams for like four weeks in a row.
So, I'm gonna like chill.
I'm gonna...
Next week there won't be a member stream.
But the week after that will be a member stream.
So, um...
I can make a good movies watch along for that one.
Yeah, it'll be a good...
A good movie.
But I...
But a good movie in my definition of a good...
It's gonna be...
What I think is a good movie.
What?
I have good taste, guys.
My taste are pretty good.
What are you guys talking about?
I have really good taste in movie.
It's gonna be a good movie, guys.
Don't worry.
It'll be my definition of a good movie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, Smetty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't...
Sam will never do something like that.
They want...
They don't care.
They want you to fight.
They need you to fight.
The more you fight, the more you wanna buy.
And the more you wanna buy, the more money they'll make.
They don't fucking care.
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, that's what I was gonna say!
Okay, so like...
I was thinking about how like...
Doe Kitty is like...
Okay, so you know like...
Hello Kitty is not an actual kitty.
Hello is like her first name.
And kitty is like her last name.
So like...
So, like, she's not an actual cat.
She's just, like...
Oh, sorry, it's Kitty.
Was it Kitty White?
Oh, sorry, Kitty White.
Sorry, Kitty is her first name and White is her last name.
I don't... I don't remember why it's, like, Hello Kitty.
Sorry, White, yeah.
Or is it Kitty is her last name?
Fuck, I don't remember.
Is it Kitty?
Kitty is... Yeah, she's a cat-shaped human.
So, is either Kitty is her first name or last name?
I think it's Kitty.
Kitty is her last name, right?
Because her sister is Mimi Kitty.
Yeah, okay, so...
Yeah, Mimi Kitty, yeah.
So...
Wait, is it?
Mimi White is Hello Kitty's...
Is White her last name?
Okay, let me double check.
I need to make sure.
Because, like, Mimi is her sister's name.
And... Okay, Mimi White.
Okay, so yeah, so her full name is actually...
Kitty White.
That's her full name.
So, she's actually a cat-shaped human.
So, she's not like an actual cat.
Because, if you guys didn't know...
Hello Kitty owns an actual cat named Charming Kitty.
That looks just like her.
So...
Hello Kitty owns an actual cat that looks just like her.
And her name is Charmy Kitty.
And...
Yeah, okay, so...
Yeah.
No, cause it's not like Goofy and Pluto.
Because Pluto is Mickey's dog.
Like, Hello Kitty...
Hello Kitty has her own pet cat.
And... The pet cat.
And then, the thing is, Pluto doesn't look like Goofy.
Her pet cat looks just like her.
Like, she even has, like, the bow and everything.
I used to really love... I used to really like Charmy Kitty.
When she first came out, she was incredibly popular.
And, like, she was, like...
She was, like, based off of more, like, bougie merch type deal.
Like, fan... Like, she was, like, fancier type merch.
Because, like, it was all about her being, like, a rich cat.
Like, a... Like, purebred cat or some shit.
But I wanted to talk about Charmy Kitty.
Cause I think it's, like, a char... Like, a...
Do-kitty, doki-bird situation.
Like...
What if I am Doki-bird's cat pet cat?
Do-kitty.
Yeah, oh yeah, so Charmy Kitty is, like, an Arista cat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I meant.
She's more so, like, an Arista cat.
And, like, what if I'm, like...
Just the pet cat of Doki-bird.
I could just be, like, a Charmy Kitty situation.
So... So, I'm a pet pet, exactly.
I'm a...
I am...
I am, like, we coexist in this universe.
This... The Doki universe.
New lore.
But yeah, I don't know.
Sanrio characters are fucking weird.
Let me... Alright, let me look at... Okay, all...
All Sanrio characters.
There's some really weird ones out there.
Okay, let's... Hello, Kitty.
Alright.
Let's see.
What the fuck is Hundrick?
There's Cake-chan?
There's a... There's a character that's just a cake?
She is a whole cake.
Cake-chan.
I don't keep up with some of these characters.
Like, Sanrio releases new characters every fucking year and I can't keep track of it anymore.
There's too many.
Okay.
New Sanrio character...
20 at 25.
Oops, sorry.
I forgot to...
Okay, Yoshi... Yoshi Kitty is selected for... For the 11th...
Wait, what?
Who's... Who's Yoshi Kitty?
The beloved... Inspired by international music icon Yoshiki has once again been selected...
Wait, there's a...
There's a Hello Kitty character based off a real person?
Who is the newest...
Oh!
Is that the newest?
No, that can't be the newest one.
Who's the newest Sanrio character?
I'm trying to look.
Newest... Newest...
Newest... Sanrio character.
Alright.
Oh, the Hana... Hana Maru Ba... Oh, I've seen this one!
This was created in 2022 before... Oh my god, the newest one was 2023?
I've seen this one around Japan.
I didn't realize it was a Sanrio character.
I thought they're... It's really cute.
It's like a little...
Ghost thing, right?
The...
This guy?
The Hana Mo...
Hana Mori...
Ba... Ba... Bake or Ba... I don't fucking...
I'm so bad at languages.
Hana Maru...
Bake?
I don't know.
I've seen like little gacha toys of it when I was in Japan.
I didn't realize it was a... It was a new Sanrio character.
I thought it was cute.
This little guy is pretty cute.
Look at him.
Or her.
It's pretty cute.
I like it.
I like the design.
What is it though?
It's a ghost with...
And then Hana Maru on his buttocks?
The fuck is that?
Oh!
It has the...
It has the little...
The udon...
The fishcake thing.
It's a shy...
Maoru Maru is a shy, mysterious ghost...
Who appears without warning to give you a Hana Maru for your daily efforts.
Everyone has their own Hana Maru...
Bake that comes in a different form, like a future goal and an important memory...
That motivates them to keep working hard every day.
Wait, that's cute!
What is this?
Hana Maru goods?
Oh my God!
Look, he's encouraging you to...
Buy more stuff for capitalism.
Good for you, Hana Maru.
Good.
Good for you, let's go.
They're like... I don't know what this means, but all I can think about is like...
He's like, yes, buy more stuff.
If you wanna be...
Hana Maru fan, remember to buy all these items from Sanrio.
I don't know what it actually says, but this is what it...
This is what it's saying to me.
It's like, yes.
Yes.
Keep buying.
Yeah, I didn't know this was Sanrio.
I mean, I guess it does look like Sanrio stuff, like the Sanrio style.
Oh look, and he's like with all the other...
All the other characters.
Alright, who else is new?
Who else is the newest?
Okay, list of...
Sanrio next kawaii project.
Meet Sanrio's top 10 new characters.
Wow.
Who are they?
Oh my God, I'm so excited.
Oh, there was like a poll.
Oh!
So like, oh I see.
I see.
So there was like a merch poll.
And like, whoever wins the merch poll...
Becomes the next Sanrio character.
So like, Hana Maru won.
Oh man, okay, not gonna lie.
The other guys look so...
Pudu Pudu on pizza.
Is that...
What the fuck is...
What the fuck is Pudu Pudu on pizza?
It looks like poop.
It looks like...
It looks like fucking poop.
Okay, but like...
Hana Maru had like zero competition.
Like, I mean like...
I'm sorry, but like what the fuck was his competition?
There's... Okay, I would say that Kumal...
Kumalino...
Was...
Is...
I think Kumalino is a pretty cute design.
But like...
Kaburen Boku Rabu...
Creamy Afternoon...
Haranochi...
Okay, that is...
That's not...
This is barely any competition for this guy.
Like, all the other guys are like...
So generic compared to like...
I guess like the concept of Hana Maru is really cute too.
Like the artwork.
But like all these other guys like...
What the fuck...
I think the bear is really cute.
The...
The Kumalino is really cute.
Just cause I like the...
I just...
I think this little cute...
I like his little outfit there.
Yeah, he looks really dapper.
But everybody else was like...
Barely...
Like, what the fuck is...
Puraren Pukara...
Like...
Looks like...
He looks like a...
He looks like...
A psychopath.
Like...
He looks like someone...
Somebody...
Something you see in a creepypasta.
Yeah, I think the Kumalino is really cute.
But other than that, there's like barely any competition there.
I miss...
I'm...
I haven't bought Sanrio stuff in a long time though.
It's been a while since I bought Sanrio stuff.
At least just cause like...
I've just been so busy.
I don't really shop a lot either.
Yeah, like...
What the fuck?
This is barely a competition!
Like, look at this.
What kind of...
I'm just looking at like...
The competition on who would be like...
The next Sanrio...
Sanrio character.
And like...
There's barely...
This is...
Like, okay.
Yeah, it's literally the two bears.
The two bears, I would say...
Oh my god, the...
Fucking...
Okay, like...
Remember when I said the guy looks like a goddamn psychopath?
Like...
That looks like a fucking killer.
Like, look at him.
Look at that guy.
It's just...
He looks like he's gonna kill me.
He's observing.
He looks like he has committed...
Like...
He looks like the guy you first go to...
As like the first...
Like...
The first suspect...
Like, for a murder.
He's a bad, bad man.
He looks...
He's watching me.
He's seen too much.
The prime suspect...
Like, he'll be like...
He has an alibi...
But you know he did it.
You know he fucking did it.
But like, other than that...
Like...
This guy barely had...
Like, cause the art style is really cute too.
He knows.
Yeah, like...
Looking at all this competition...
The only ones that I think...
Could have beat...
Hanamaru...
Was literally the two bears.
Like, oh my god, he's so cute though.
The little outfit he has.
He's like a little waiter too.
He looks like a little waiter.
Aw, he's so cute.
I wish he won.
I wish that the two little bears won.
But I think it's just...
I guess it looks a little too generic.
Cause like, Hanamaru seems like a more...
It seems like a more unique concept.
And IP versus just two...
Two fucking bears.
Matrix, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your collab with Mint was funny, including two horses.
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed the collab.
I always love collabing with Mint.
I feel like we just...
We just bounce off each other really well.
And then, like...
I never know what to expect...
When I collab with her.
And...
You know, things always go pretty crazy.
Every time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
TastyDs, thank you for the super chat.
You're gonna do a sleep clinic to check your sleep apnea?
I still haven't checked my sleep apnea.
If I do have sleep apnea.
But, like, the nasal...
I don't do the nasal strips a lot.
But...
It does help my sleep a lot.
Because, like...
In the past, I used to sleep with my mouth.
Like, through my mouth.
But, ever since I did the nasal strip.
Even without it.
I started, like, breathing through my nose when I'm sleeping.
So, when I go to sleep.
I sleep with my mouth open.
But, ever since I did the nasal strip.
Like, I've been sleeping with my mouth closed.
And just, like...
You know...
Just...
Like, breathing through my nose when I'm sleeping.
I still think I snore.
Because, when I do wake up.
I do feel, like, dryness in my throat sometimes.
So, I still think I'm still snoring.
But, I'm not sure yet, obviously.
Like, I don't fucking know.
I live alone.
I think the only way to test it out.
Is if I, like, record myself on the phone.
But then, I'm, like, worried about what I...
Like, I'm worried.
What if I just start sleep talking?
And, like, I think it's really freaky.
If I listen to myself sleep.
And I just...
I don't know.
What if I just say something really fucking crazy in my sleep.
And being, like...
I'm gonna kill you.
I don't know if I wanna, like...
Experience that.
I'm feeling, like...
I'm gonna kill you.
And all that.
Like, that's, like, an actual...
Like, not fear.
But, like...
That's something I don't wanna find out about myself.
I...
Cause, like...
I don't...
No.
I know, like, I have...
I...
I have slept talk before in the past.
So, I...
I'm scared of, like, listening to my recording.
And then, I just say some fucking demonic shit.
Oh.
But, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, I need to get...
First, like...
I need to get, like...
I know I have more...
Cough drops somewhere.
Give me a sec, guys.
Let me find some extra cough drops real quick.
Trying to find my...
I know I have extra cough...
Cough drops?
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
Just had to get extra cough drops real quick.
No, it's not food!
Every time he hears, like, the crinkling of stuff, he thinks it's food.
He thinks...
He thinks it's fucking food.
He's like, Are you trying to feed me?
No, you...
You hungry dog.
It's not food.
Can't open it.
Oh my god.
No, it's not food.
You're not allowed to eat it.
Food time?
He's always hungry.
I don't think he'll ever be full.
He's, like, incredibly food motivated.
Like, I think you can kidnap my dog if you just give him treats.
Like, a lady actually tried to do that as a joke.
I told you that story before, right?
Yeah, I did.
Like, there was this lady walking her dogs.
And then, like...
Dad really liked her.
Because she had treats on her.
And she was, like, walking...
I think she was a dog walker or something.
And she was, like, walking two dogs.
And then, like, she was giving him treats and stuff.
And then she was like, Haha, what if I just, like, take him away?
Do you think he'll, like, look back at you?
And he didn't look back.
He didn't look back.
So I think you can actually kidnap...
I mean, I wouldn't say...
He wouldn't feel like it's a kidnapping.
He would just be like, Freedom!
But yeah.
Let's see.
Aphelion.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Dokia.
Love the Goodnight Dragoons streams.
They're some of my favorites.
Thanks for the good vibes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've been...
I'm glad you enjoy Goodnight Dragoons.
And I'm happy to bring it back for you guys.
I just figured, like, you know...
I did took, like...
A three-day...
Was it three or four days?
I don't remember.
Sunday, Monday, Tuesday.
I streamed on Wednesday, right?
Yeah, I did.
I did a gorilla stream on Wednesday.
But it's technically a four-day break.
Well, it wasn't a break for me.
It was a...
Four -day locked in the Marvel Rivals dungeon.
And getting nothing in return.
So, I did feel bad.
Because I didn't stream.
For, like...
Technically, I didn't stream for four days.
So, I'm gonna schedule stuff for four days.
So, I was like...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna bring back Goodnight Dragoons.
So, you don't hate me.
You'll be like...
This is it.
This is the final straw.
I'm gonna finally unsubscribe.
And then, you see Goodnight Dragoons.
And you're like...
Never... Oh, never mind.
All is forgiven now.
The Dragoons have been appeased.
All is...
You have been forgiven.
You are forgiven.
Oh, yeah.
Tyler, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Word through the grapevine is your dignity.
Can we be bought?
Can we get a...
Can we get a super chat, Tyler?
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, just...
You think...
You think that's how cheap my dignity is?
I am a high-class cat.
I am a house cat, alright?
I come from a very...
A very...
Rich line of pure-blooded cats.
You think $20 is enough for my dignity?
I am an indoor-inside house cat.
Alright?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A very prestigious...
Mr.
Stan, thank you for the stacca soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway...
Let's see, where was I?
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Aren't you a bit too intelligent to be a pet?
I guess...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for thinking I'm smart.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Akuma, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, it's based off of Ato's character too?
Like the singer?
The singer Ato?
Ato?
Is it really?
I didn't know that.
Hanamaru?
I mean, to be fair, I found out about Hanamaru, like, just now.
Like, not just now, but like, this week.
When I was looking at the Sanrio character rankings.
JL, thank you for the aka soup.
Thank you, thank you.
One...
Piraka.
There we go.
Thank you for the aka soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Orca!
Dorkness, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What was I gonna say?
There's something I wanna talk about, but I forgot.
What did I wanna say?
It was a good attempt.
You know, you tried.
Tried, good for you.
Good for you.
Oh my god, did you guys see?
Did you guys see?
Okay, I know I talked about...
Okay, so you know how I mentioned about AI stuff?
So...
I thought it was really crazy that...
There's, like...
You can...
Like, there was...
Okay, I don't know if, like, people are actually allowed to do it.
Because a judge was like, what the fuck?
But...
There was a video of this guy that tried to use an AI lawyer...
To defend his case.
And there's, like, an actual video of it.
I was like...
You know, I thought it was, like, some tech bro that tried to do it.
Because, like, you know, it would make sense.
But it's, like, some 74-year-old man.
Like, some grandpa that tried to have, like, an AI to represent them as their lawyer.
Like...
I thought...
Oh, I thought I was actually...
I thought, like, it was...
I was crazy.
I was like...
I mean, like...
It's understandable.
Like...
It's free.
But he got thrown out for it.
Like...
It's definitely cheaper than a real lawyer.
I have to admit.
It's definitely cheaper.
But still, like...
That's so stupid.
Mizuki, thank you for the...
Welcome to Tomato Fire.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my god, they are taking our jobs.
Oh my...
Okay.
And...
And, like...
I remember reading something about how there's gonna be a new season of South Park.
But, like...
You guys don't understand, like...
How long it's been since South Park has released an actual new season.
Because the creators were like...
Yeah.
It's really hard these days to write for a full season now.
Because there's not enough content for us to make for each episode.
So that's why we're doing these...
That's why they've been doing the...
The movie stuff.
Because they were like...
They were like...
Yeah.
It's so hard to find and make enough content for...
For just...
We're just so burnt out.
So the fact that they're releasing a new...
Too much shit has been happening.
Every day.
There is so much content.
That there's just too much shit happening in this world now.
That they're like...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, yeah.
There's enough content for us.
Also, thank you so much for the raid.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much, Azura.
Thank you, thank you.
But, yeah, like...
I thought...
I'm so excited.
I love South Park.
I'm sorry.
I'm so...
I'm so excited.
Like, cause Canada's involved now.
Apparently, there's gonna be an episode...
Dedicated to Canada.
So, like, I'm looking forward to see, like, what...
What they're gonna do.
And, like, the song that they used for the trailer for South Park...
Was literally Blame Canada.
But, like, spooky.
It was like...
Spooky Blame Canada.
I'll show you guys.
There you go.
I'll link the trailer.
The fact that they're actually making a new season is crazy.
Like I said, they've, like...
They said...
The creators have said in interviews were like...
We just don't have enough content.
It's, like, to make a full season.
So, we decided to do the movies.
Cause then we can focus everything on just...
On that one...
Like, these, like, hour-long episodes and stuff.
The horror...
Horror...
It's, like, you know, like the...
Like...
One, two, Freddy's coming for you.
But it's like...
Blame Canada.
But, yeah, I'm really...
I'm really looking forward to the new season.
Just cause Canada's gonna be involved in it.
Hmm...
Oh, yeah.
You know...
Speaking of...
Speaking of, like, Canada...
You know I made a joke in the hunting stream?
How, like...
My dog was trying to...
Cross the border to Canada.
You guys know that, like...
Americans have been trying to, like...
Illegally cross the border to live in Canada.
And, like...
We have, like, a Canadian border patrol now.
To stop Americans from illegally coming into Canada.
I thought it was so funny.
We have people...
I know...
I know it's wild.
Like, the Mounties are, like, patrol...
Patrolling the Canadian-American border.
To make sure no one crossed...
The Americans don't cross over.
It's so...
It's so fucking funny to me.
It's just like, what's up?
They're like, alright, turn around.
They're like...
You guys hear about that?
That's so wild.
I know.
That's actually...
That's actually so wild.
I just think it's so funny.
That the Mounties are, like, patrolling the border right now.
Yeah.
Alright, I just wanted...
I just wanted to mention that.
Anyway.
Other than that...
I don't know how to turn this table.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat, Mike.
Anyway.
Change of topic.
But I just recently found out that Dreamworks was originally gonna make...
Dreamworks was originally gonna make a McDonald's movie.
And there was, like, a leaked concept art of the Ronald McDonald's family.
And I was like, that shit is so fucking scary.
It's okay.
I saw the...
I saw...
Like, it was, like...
Dreamworks was concepting a McDonald's movie.
And they're, like, you know, doing concept art and everything and pitching it and stuff.
But they had the rights to do it.
And...
Oh my god.
Okay, let me show you the concept art.
It looks so fucking...
Like...
That looks like...
It looks so scary.
Like...
I'm...
Okay, but...
Also, it's really fucking funny that there's, like, um...
They made, like, you know, the dream...
The, like, Pixar mom.
The Pixar mom.
Even though this is Dreamworks, they made the Pixar mom of, like, Ronald McDonald's wife.
With the hourglass figure and everything.
But oh my god, this is terrifying.
Like, this is actually...
Oh yeah, the hot clown kink.
No, you...
I know that's a...
I know that's somebody's kink right there.
When they want their...
When they want their women to dress up like a clown.
Stay away from his wife.
I'm loving it, alright.
But, like, his children, though.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with his son?
Like, what is...
Oh my god.
I don't know, his children...
His children's freaky as hell.
His son actually got that...
His son looks like he was not born right.
That's all I can say.
There's something wrong with that boy.
I'm loving it, alright.
I don't...
I don't think he's okay.
Would you...
That kid ain't right, boy.
That kid ain't right.
Stay away from that boy.
Let's see.
Stub!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Toki, prepare a serious chat.
Oh, hey!
Thank you again for the rate.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Medi!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you still buy any plushies for yourself even when dad is destroying around?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes.
Because, like, it's so weird.
He's so weird.
Okay, so if I don't, like, specifically tell him not to...
Okay, so I have a giant ass otter.
I can't show the otter, by the way, because it's sort of, like, I bought it at a place near me.
So, like, if you see the otter, people will know where I...
People will, like, know where to get it.
But I have a giant ass otter plushie that I, like, sleep with.
Like, I cuddle it and everything.
And, yeah, it's too local.
So, like...
So...
I was, like, I told my dog.
I was, like, no!
No!
Like, maybe I can look at it and I'll be, like, no!
And then he has not done anything with the plushie.
But, like, if I don't give him a warning...
If I don't give him any warnings at all, he will destroy it.
So, like, obviously, he destroyed the dragoon plushie.
Like, your ancestor.
Because, I...
You know, he fucking...
He fucking broke into one of the boxes and just stole it.
And was, like, pretending to be super sneaky about it.
So, um...
So, like, he, like, fucking ripped it apart and everything.
So, obviously, like, he...
I didn't give him the warning.
I also have, like, a sleeping Pikachu that's sitting on my windowsill.
And I literally showed it to him.
And I was, like, no!
No!
And then he hasn't touched it.
He hasn't touched it at all.
And then the windowsill is, like, you know, at, like, I love...
Like, it's not even, like, far.
It's not even hard to reach.
He can literally grab it if he wants to.
But he doesn't do it because I already warned him.
I was, like, you don't...
Because he knows.
He knows when he fucked up.
Because when I found out, he, like, stole the dragoon plushie.
He instantly hid from me.
And, like, looked at me, like, guiltily.
Like, he was, like...
I'm sorry.
He's, like...
Me.
I'm sorry.
My bad.
But, yeah.
So, he doesn't...
He only...
He won't do it if I, like, specifically tell him not to.
Because I think he's scared of, like, what happened.
Because, yeah.
He's, like, oh, no.
I got the warning.
Yeah, the guilty dog look.
And everything.
Okay,
but I do that when I'm not sleeping.
Like, if I can say that when I'm not sleeping, imagine the things I could say when I am sleeping.
Because those aren't my intrusive thoughts.
I feel like...
I'm just worried that if I'm sleep talking, I'd say, like, inner deep thoughts that even I didn't.
Like, the thoughts that, like, I don't think about, but it's, like, in my soul.
Like, what if, like, I listen to the recording, and then I'm, like, so this is how I...
This is how the assassination of JFK happened.
Like that shit.
Like that.
Like, I'm, like, really worried.
I'm, like, what the fuck would I say when I...
The real thoughts.
Wait.
What the...
I don't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Anyway.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
CJ, thank you for the super chat.
Confidential information.
What does that mean?
I guess we'll never know, because I'll never record myself sleep talking.
Well, the official documents are out now.
That's what you think.
Yeah, sure.
Official.
Tyranna, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, we aren't like dad who could leave you that easily.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Megan, thank you for the super chat.
Hey, Doki.
Been a while since I've seen a stream and forgot how enjoyable they are.
Also, do you think I could tug your...
How do you pronounce it?
Ahoge?
Is that how you pronounce it?
Well, it's not...
Which one?
The one at the bottom?
No.
Ahegao.
Ahoge.
Ahe...
Ahegao.
Um, what?
Wait, what?
What did I say?
I was just pronouncing stuff on the...
I was just...
But now...
Oh, no.
I got baited.
I got fucking baited.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What was that in the super chat?
Mizuki, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome,
welcome.
Moro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think they just can't compete what crazy reality is at the moment.
Oh, that's true.
Every day is like...
New shit coming up.
Oh my god!
Okay, I don't watch Aisho Speed.
But like, I saw clips of his trip to China.
And like, oh my god.
I felt so homesick watching it.
Cause like...
Oh my god.
Like, okay, there's a lot of stuff that...
Like, it's been a while since I've been back to China and Hong Kong.
So like...
The...
I was feeling like incredibly like homesick watching it.
And...
And like...
Like, the stuff he was showing.
Like, I did not realize there were like...
Oh my god, there's like so many new things back like now.
Because it's been like, I think...
More than six years, I think.
More than five years since I've been back.
And it made me incredibly homesick.
I thought it was so sweet.
Okay, so like...
There was this girl.
I think this was during...
In Hong Kong.
When she was...
When he was in...
Okay, apparently the officials in Hong Kong were like, Speed did everything in China.
We didn't arrange anything for him.
This is unacceptable.
But like...
Did you guys see the one about how...
He like...
There was this girl.
I think this was from Hong Kong, right?
And he was like...
This girl and her...
Like, he was with this girl.
And like, the chat was being like really mean to the girl.
Because like her voice was like super high-pitched and stuff.
And he was like, don't let...
Don't let anyone say that about you.
And like...
Just be stronger.
And I was like, oh my god, that's so fucking sweet.
I was like...
That's so...
Yeah, that was really sweet of him.
And then...
I didn't realize we have flying cars.
When they showed him on a flying car, I was like, we have that?
I was like, wait, what?
We have flying cars?
Since when?
And then it was basically like...
Okay, but to be fair, the flying car was like basically a giant fucking drone that you can sit on.
Yeah, it was like...
Okay, so the base is a car.
Like the car thing.
And then they just put like drones at the bottom.
And then it just...
It's like...
It's like, you know, like Amazon delivery.
Where you're delivering, you know, drones are delivering packages.
So like, drones can now deliver a fucking human being.
It was like, it's a giant fucking drone.
Now we can deliver you.
Wait, let me...
I'll show you guys.
I saw the clip.
I was like, what the fuck?
That shit looks...
Okay, not gonna lie.
That shit looks so fucking scary.
A human-sized drone.
Alright, let me show you.
You became the first streamer to drive a fly.
Like, it's just a drone.
It is.
Oh, wait, sorry.
That's subpar.
I linked you guys to subpar trailer again.
Okay, wait.
Here we go.
Look at this.
It's literally...
It's a fucking Amazon drone delivering a person to you.
Bro, it's like...
The inside is like a car.
It's literally...
Yeah.
That looks so scary though.
Like, if I was like in that...
I don't know if I can say it's safer than a helicopter.
I think like...
I don't know.
No, cause like a helicopter is like a lot different from what the fuck...
Whatever I'm looking at right now.
It's an inverted helicopter.
What if we just...
No, it's literally a drone.
I don't know.
I can't tell if it's safer.
I legitimately cannot tell.
Because like...
Helicopters are also like...
I don't know.
I don't find helicopters very safe either.
It was very interesting.
I think the whole...
I show speed...
Cause I...
I'm not the audience for speed streams.
Obviously, he's like...
I know he's like...
He seems like a really genuine guy though.
Cause like, you know...
I feel like the content he does is incredibly creative.
And like very...
Fun to watch where he travels around to different countries.
And you know, experiencing their culture and everything.
And actually like seems interested in learning about other people's cultures.
And like...
I wish...
In my time, we had like...
For like the generation...
Of content creators that I watched.
That...
We had more people like speed.
Because like...
You know...
He seems like a very genuine person.
And his content is like...
You know, so...
His content, he's actually...
He's actually like trying to like...
Introduce different cultures and stuff.
To like different...
To like...
To people around the world.
And yeah, he created like...
And like he has fans from...
Yeah, we had...
We had Jake and Logan Paul.
Yeah, I like that he highlights like the different cultures.
Like different cultures and stuff from all the places he visited and stuff.
But yeah, it was so interesting.
I really...
I enjoyed the clips I saw.
Of his entire trip throughout...
Of his entire trip in China.
It was like...
It was very interesting.
Like it would pop up in my Twitter feed.
And I got like actually homesick.
I was like, oh my gosh.
I miss living there.
And like obviously...
Like I miss the malls.
The malls were fucking crazy back there.
No, he's not...
He's like...
He's an actual...
He's a really good...
I think he's good at...
He's really, really good at what he does.
And he's like...
He likes to communicate and like...
Talk to people from around the world.
Like he unites cultures from around the world and stuff.
I wanna go back to Hong Kong this year.
But like I also like wanna...
You know, I'm like...
I wanna go back when things are much more calm.
In my life.
When things are more calm in my life, then I'd go back.
But right now...
Right now, I'm obviously like...
I'm always busy almost every day.
And like, you know, things have been like...
You know, so chaotic and stuff.
So yeah, I'll go back one day.
One day.
I wanna go back this year.
Let's see.
Let's...
I have no...
What?
What is this?
Is this the one where he like...
Kills him?
Oh yeah!
I've seen it.
And he was like...
What the fuck?
I've seen that clip.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And everybody was like...
What the fuck?
Like, you didn't know what the fuck happened.
Yeah, I sent a...
I sent a clip of it.
That shit was crazy.
That shit was fucking crazy.
I remember seeing it.
If you ever thought wrestling was fake...
Let's see.
What?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know what that was referenced to.
I've read the super chat too late.
I'm sorry.
Cat fake gravity.
He killed that kid.
It...
Vivas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was at a birthday party for my friend's 30th birthday today and someone gave him your merch.
The body pillow.
That's so evil.
I love it.
His mother and grandpa were confused.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my...
That's so fucking evil.
But like...
That's a dragoon right there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good for him.
I hope he had a good birthday.
In front of the whole family.
Oh my god.
A soccer clip just showed up on my...
On my Twitter timeline.
And I just remembered about the fact that Ronaldo is a fucking character in the fighting game.
Did you guys see the trailer of the Ronaldo character?
And like his movesets and everything.
Alright, Ronaldo...
Is it Ronaldo or is it...
Oh yeah, it was Fatal Fury, right?
Yeah.
They showed a trailer...
Of Ronaldo.
Or not Fatal Fury.
Yeah, Fatal Fury.
Yeah, here's the trailer.
I thought it was...
It was so funny.
It's not even him.
He doesn't even voice act his own character.
Who the fuck is Juan Felipe Sierra?
Like...
Bro, he doesn't even...
Bro, you can't even do the bare minimum.
Of voice acting yourself?
Like...
He doesn't...
I was like, who the fuck is Juan Felipe Sierra?
Like...
Why does it look so...
Why does it look good?
Because Ronaldo doesn't voice act his own fucking character.
It's funny.
That's crazy.
I'm like...
When I saw that trailer...
He was...
He just got into a video game.
Well, I know for sure what...
What...
Like...
How many people are gonna...
Like, who are the players are gonna play this game just for Ronaldo?
It might not even be...
Like, they might not even be, like, fighting game fans.
They're just playing it for Ronaldo.
That's crazy.
I'm re-watching the trailer.
I'm re-watching the trailer right now.
Okay, the finisher looks so cool, though.
Imagine getting your ass beat by fucking Ronaldo.
Alright,
where was I?
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Machato Super...
Thank you, thank you.
LostPlanet2?
What's that?
It's a third person shooter.
That's sold over 2.
Why is that mixed reviews?
Is it, like...
Are they dinosaurs?
Is this a mecha game?
What is this?
Why is it mixed re...
Hold on.
Uh...
Wait, it's not even available.
Wait, you can't even get this.
Wait, we're temporarily disabling the purchase option on Steam while we investigate the matter.
We'll keep you informed.
Wait, what happened?
Wait.
Wait, it's been...
How long has this game been delisted for?
Hold on.
Wait, it's been...
Yeah, it's delisted.
It's been delisted for at least, like, a month plus now.
It's literally unplayable.
I feel nothing but rage.
Caveat for leaving this game for dead.
Oh my God, what happened?
LostPlanet...
I'm looking at LostPlanet2.
Apparently, this game has been, like, delisted for, like...
Like, almost two months now.
Yeah, like, multiplayer is unplayable.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, man, that you just found out that the game doesn't exist anymore.
I'm sorry that this is how you found out you're sharing your love for your game and now the game doesn't exist anymore.
This is how you had to find out.
Valentine, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I haven't heard...
I've heard of clown phobia, but not clown.
Yeah, no, there's apparently a surprising amount of people that are sexually attracted to clowns.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, it's a real thing.
It's actually, like, a real...
I think it's because of, like, Harley Quinn, honestly.
I won't be surprised if, like, Harley Quinn helped with that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Only sexy clowns.
But, like, what makes a sexy clown sexy?
Let's see.
Where was I?
Let's stop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I remind you that according to the X-Men movies, JFK was a muni.
Also, it's, like, 100 degrees where I am.
Please send some of the Canadians Canada coldness down here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of X-Men, I just found out that, like, Charles Xavier has been able to walk for years now.
Like, why would you do that to him?
How dare you make him walk?
I can't believe it.
I was so looking forward to play him in a wheelchair.
Like...
How dare you cure...
How dare you cure his disability?
Bro, I was so looking forward to play
him in his wheelchair.
What happened?
You could have represented the wheelchair gaming.
How dare they make him walk?
Like, why does he have...
I don't understand.
Make him sit down.
Someone...
Someone get his back.
Imagine the movement.
I swear to God.
No, I...
It's confirmed that...
He's not gonna be in a wheelchair.
Because in the Corcoa...
Corcoa map...
Where...
The fuck...
The stupid...
Mutant safe haven.
That there's a...
There's a statue of him.
Of him walk...
Like, there's a statue of him in his walking form.
So like...
It's confirmed that he's not gonna be on...
He's not gonna be like...
In a...
In a wheelchair.
I'm so sad.
And then like...
I was seeing people debate about it.
They're like...
The Marvel fans.
Were like...
Oh my God.
I hate how like...
People don't know that like...
He can walk now.
Like...
You can tell who's a fake fan.
For not knowing that he can walk for like...
Years now.
And I was like...
Because him being in a wheelchair...
Is so much cooler.
Like...
You don't understand.
Everybody can fucking walk.
Well, not obviously.
Not everybody.
But like...
Almost all the characters in Marvel Rivals can fucking walk.
I'd wanna play a guy in a wheelchair.
Rolling around.
Running over people.
Like...
That's cool.
I wanna play as a wheelchair guy in Marvel Rivals.
And then just start fucking going...
Like...
Why can't I have that?
Why can't I have him do fucking wheelies?
Like...
I want him to do wheelies.
Imagine the...
Imagine the wheelchair skins.
Exactly!
Like...
I'm just saying.
Yeah.
He's wheelchair bound.
And like...
Most of the...
Like...
Non-comic adaptations.
We could make it hover.
For all of it.
I wanted a Tokyo Drift on the wheelchair.
Like, is that too much to ask for?
Like...
And then there's like...
I can see...
Can't believe people don't know that he can...
Yeah, cause the design is fucking boring.
Oh my god.
Do you know what he looks like when he can walk?
He's like some fucking nerd.
Alright.
Charles Xavier.
His like walk...
His like walking design is so fucking stupid.
I hate it.
I...
His new design is so lame.
Give me back the wheelchair.
Like...
He just wears black tights.
It's so lame.
Look at how lame he is.
I wanna fucking give him a swirly and stuff him in the goddamn locker.
Like...
Alright, let me show you guys.
Let me show you guys how fucking lame it looks.
Now he's just standing.
Alright.
This is what he looks like.
Look how lame he looks.
Like, what is he wearing?
He's just...
He's just wearing black tights.
Like, what the fuck is he...
He looks like the fucking Mr. Fantastic skin.
Like...
He looks like...
Yeah, he looks like the maker.
Like, why is he buff?
You've been wheelchair bound for, like, years.
Why are you buff?
I don't...
That's not how muscles work.
You were not moving your body enough to have that.
You're old!
What's with the helmet?
No, that's him!
That's actually him.
It's not the maker.
It's him when he...
When he's...
His new design.
His stupid fucking new design.
I hate this.
Dude, like, he stepped out of Warframe.
Zero, I think he was a super...
It is ugly!
That's like...
I don't understand how, like, the Marvel fans...
Like, the comic book Marvel fans are, like, being so pretentious about how they're like...
Oh, um, I don't understand.
Like, they're like...
I can't believe they don't know that Charles Xavier hasn't been in a wheelchair for fucking...
Cause it's boring!
Like, look at this man!
I wanna stuff him in a fucking locker!
All the other guys, they are so iconic.
Yes, Lay.
And then there's him!
Like, what the fuck am I looking at?
He's so...
He's so boring!
Like, okay.
If I google Charles Xavier, they're all in wheelchairs!
Why play this guy?
When I can play...
When I can play this guy.
Doing fucking wheelies.
Doing a Tokyo Drift.
Alright, this is...
Okay, why play him when I can play him?
He does the...
Like...
Imagine the possibilities!
The things I can do!
Oh, Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He just, he lost...
Yeah, I know, he lost his aura.
He really did.
At least...
Okay, if you don't want to make him look like...
Sir Patrick Stewart.
At least make him look like James McAvoy.
Because at least that's hot.
At least give me McAvoy.
In his first class uniform.
I'll take that.
At least...
True.
At least give me James McAvoy in first class.
I'll take that over the stupid ass...
Black tighties that he has.
So that's what this is about.
Oh my god.
Or just give me this.
I don't care.
Okay, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not...
Look, I'm not demanding much.
Or just give me this.
I'll even take the fucking hover wheelchair.
Like, I'll even take this.
Give me this.
I'll take this too.
Like, just put him back in the chair.
No one...
Of course no one knows about the Mr. Fucking...
Fucking a nerd.
Of course no one knows.
Of course no one knows about this design.
Like, the mainstream.
It's so boring.
It's actually...
Why would anybody know about this design?
It's so fucking boring.
Like, it's just...
Like, why is it so tight?
Why?
Like, from this...
This to this.
Like...
Like, please.
Someone...
Someone find where he lives and get a crowbar.
Like, I don't know.
Like...
Why does he have abs?
No, it's him.
It's actually...
Like, why can't he walk just now?
Why...
Like...
So, like...
Alright, so apparently...
He dies yet again.
And then he was reborn.
So, and...
He was reborn.
And then he can walk now.
Like, that's the whole thing.
He dies a million times.
But, you know, this is the time where he was born again.
But this time with the ability to, like, walk.
Yeah.
That's basically how it happens.
I just...
But yeah, so...
So, most...
He's not gonna be in a wheelchair and that makes me sad.
I thought it'd be so cool to play, like, a wheelchair support character.
Just, like, the possibilities of you just, like...
You know, like...
You know, like, there's an ability where you could, like, you know, run someone over in your wheelchair.
Like...
I thought that would be, like...
I thought that would be really fun to do.
It would be really funny in-game.
That would... Yeah, exactly.
So I get boring-ass fucking guy in a black tight suit.
With, like, Mr. Van...
Like, Mr. Fantastic-looking-ass here.
Anyway, that's how I like to end my day.
That's how I like to end my stream, guys.
That's...
This rant is how I like to end my stream.
Because, um...
Because I'm tired now.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna head off now.
Oh yeah, Professor...
Instead of Professor X, we get Professor Latex.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna rest a bit.
I'm gonna post...
For the member goons, I'm gonna post the members...
About what time the final Battle Royale event will be.
Let's hope the server is still up by then.
Because I don't know what exactly the time it's gonna shut down.
It would be awkward if it shut down.
Before then.
But hopefully, it won't be.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause to chat.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me...
Head to bed, cause...
You deserve it.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
I don't know why I said anyway, guys.
I got way too passionate about my rant.
I'll see you guys later, everyone.
Bye bye, everybody.
I hope you guys enjoyed...
Good Night, Dragoons.
It's been a long time.
So, I hope you guys sleep well now...
Or have a good rest of your day.
Bye bye, everyone.
Bye!